ustedes ya tienen una familia
constituida y tienen dos hijos que
además nacieron en colombia porque
casarse hoy además de una celebración de
amor que cambia para ustedes en cuestión
de derechos
este era su super necesario para
nosotros en el sentido de que el primero
era legalizar o transmitir a todo el
país que los matrimonios del mismo sexo
que al mismo valor que las personas
heterosexuales por otro lado por
nuestros hijos por la el cambio que
tiene esta ley de que ambos padres
podemos reconocerlos y tener las mismas
obligaciones y derechos que cualquier
otro niño eso antes en chile no pasaba
bueno sigamos hablando de eso porque la
importancia de cambiar ahora por ley
marido y mujer por cónyuges para definir
las uniones y los términos de padre y
madre por progenitor hasta hoy ustedes
creen que se vulneraban los derechos de
sus hijos
si por completo o sea no teníamos las
mismas oportunidades
de poder socorrer a nuestros hijos si a
uno le pasaba algo en uno o nuestro hijo
el que no era él
por género biológico no podía sentirlo
no podía estar ahí con él no podía
llevarlo y ni siquiera a ponerse unas
vacunas
si alguno de nosotros nos pasaba algo
nuestro hijo quería que a manos de
nuestros familiares y no con nuestro
esposo
bien como abre esta ley entonces las
posibilidades para que más niños y niñas
en situación de vulnerabilidad sean
adoptados y que se restituya su derecho
a una familia y recordemos para el
contexto de los televidentes que hasta
el día de hoy solamente uno de los
padres podría efectuar el proceso de
adopción y el otro pues quedaba en nada
de hecho hasta ahora había que separarse
para poder optar a la opción para que un
padre pudiera estar dentro del proceso y
luego volver a unirse era una cosa que
no tenía ningún sentido
efectivamente y ahora con este cambio la
idea es que no haya diferencia entre las
personas que postulan ese ranking se
clasifican para optar a la adopción de
los niños que están necesitados de
familia
bueno y finalmente ya para despedirlos
quiero preguntarles eso y chile con esta
nueva ley un lugar más seguro para
expresar la diversidad
totalmente totalmente esto ya se indica
que el país lo legitimiza puede que
siguen existiendo algunos grupos que
estén en contra pero finalmente eso no
ya no es tanto al estado no respaldó una
ley que tiene que respetar eso lo que
vale como un lineamiento el cambio
cultural cine